in this lesson we're going to talk about
the median so what is the median well
the median basically gives you a sense
of the middle okay so when you think of
median think middle mean is the average
median is the middle so how do you find
the middle well if you have a list of
quantities or numbers you want to put
them in order from lowest to highest and
what you would do is you would count
like this towards the middle so in this
case we had an odd number of elements we
found that middle element and that's
going to be the median but what happens
if you have an even number of you know
quantities well look at this example
here we've got 3 and 12
then 4 and 10
and then when we get to the middle here
we have 6 and 8. so it's there's two in
the middle so what do we do well all we
do is we average them we add them
together and we divide by two so six
plus eight is fourteen divided by
divided by two is seven you can see
seven is right in the middle in between
those those two numbers so sometimes on
the act they might ask you a question
like you know what happens to the median
if you add
you know one number that's below the
median and one number that's above the
median well this would still be the same
middle number it wouldn't change but say
you added two numbers that were above
the median then it would shift the
median to the right if you had added two
numbers that were to the left of the
median then it would shift the median
you know lower to the left but if you're
adding the same number on both sides
it's going to keep the median the same
because that's still going to be the
middle number so just understanding this
concept of median and middle is
important let's go to this example see
if you can do this one so it says what
is the median height of the 15 students
listed in this histogram so you can see
here's the number of students one two
three four five and the given heights
here 61 60 inches through 65 inches is
the height
okay so pause the video see if you can
do that
and
what you would do is you'd say well
what's the middle of 15 well
that's going to be let's see right about
7 or 8 right so it's right there in the
middle it's going to be actually the
eighth student okay but when you look at
this you can see here's one student
here's two students that's three
students here's four more that's seven
the eighth student is going to be in
this block right here so it's going to
be a 63 inches is their height now if
you're not sure okay with that that
middle number here i'm just going to
show you one way you can write these out
there's not that many 10 11 12
13
14 15 so you can see 1 and 15 2 and 14 3
and 13 4 and 12 5 and 11 6 and 10
7 and 9 you can see 8 is that middle
number right so
8 is going to fall in this
interval right here so it looks like
that median height is 63 inches so
definitely an important concept to
understand i'll see you in the next
lesson